take a look at this story from Breitbart
this is great Tim cast's good friend
Malcolm Nance says GOP becoming an
Insurgency we may have to fight our
neighbors okay whoa well guys I'm
worried because Malcolm Nance he's he's
got a gun and I saw that picture of him
in in military gear when he went to
Ukraine and you know terrifying he knows
what he's doing this is interesting are
we gonna listen to this Malcolm Dance
Center speaking at all well it's five
minutes of him just like diarrheaing
from his mouth essentially he's talking
about the United States
no but it should be it's a good verb uh
he's not wrong that we are facing some
sort of Insurgency but I believe it's a
Federal Reserve it's a fascist attempt
at a coup basically since 1913 you know
Rockefeller JP Morgan they wanted
control of the country so they created
this this private bank to run our our
finances and we have yet to break free
so in that he's right we are in trouble
and we have been co-opted but he points
the finger at Donald Trump which is very
annoying because I feel like it's the
bank the banking industry he thinks it's
people that parent-teacher conferences
right yeah he thinks it's his neighbors
that's terrifying I think Ian's thinking
correctly when he says that someone
above us who's trying to pit us against
each other that's correct I'm just
imagining like Malcolm Nance like walks
out of his house and there's like a guy
in like cargo khaki cargo shorts with
like a tucked in polo shirt and he goes
howdy neighbor and Nance goes brutally
attacking him that's fake gun you're far
right so let me let me I want to read
this quote but I really don't want to he
said you can call what is happening in
Insurgency we have heard that term in
Foreign Wars recently in Iraq today we
uh he says to talk about why you apply
the term Insurgency to what you see here
as a person's an ongoing threat of
domestic extremists oh that was that was
uh as early in asking him he said I was
reading their forms I was reading their
own intelligence about what they
intended to do it was pretty clear at
that point that they were going to try
to either overthrow the government or
they were going to settle in for a
long-term series of destabilizing
actions using a political party the
Republican party has their political
base and then using violence threat of
violent extremism as a way to manifest
change in the street I just want to say
it the Gen the goal of January 6 we
thought was to was to stop Trump from
running it really does feel in my
opinion the goal is to start a civil war
that's what it sounds like yeah the the
end result of a non-adversarial
just smear campaign show trial it is
similar to the things we've seen in
other countries when people are trying
to destabilize and destroy a government
it makes me think of the burning of the
reichstag and what Hitler did well we
don't know that Hitler this is different
he said the Communists no no this is
more like the French Revolution
it's a show trial it's bringing people
up then that no one defends any of the
individuals no one no one's given a
chance to nobody want most people don't
want to and then they they lie cheat and
steal to present their case to try and
seize power yeah I don't think like with
the reichstag I think Hitler did it he
just chose he's like I'm gonna do it and
I'm gonna lie and then I'm gonna strip
them of their rights and in this case no
one like did it it just happened but
they're using the experience as an
opportunity to seize to throw people in
jail without a trial to enhance security
I don't think that's the goal of January
6th they already threw people in jail
without a trial put them in solitary
January 6 is is fomenting Discord in
this country it is convincing people of
nonsense psychotic BS like this Malcolm
Nance is radicalized he is as
radicalized as you can be he's saying he
needs to fight his neighbors yo if I
would have told you six years ago that
MSNBC personality would go on TV and say
we may have to fight our neighbors
would you have believed me you'd be like
oh come on then if I said if the year is
20 2015. let's go seven years you know
nobody believes Trump's going to win and
you go back in time and you go to any
random person and say seven years from
now several uh presidential
Administration officials former
officials will have been arrested by the
incoming Administration prominent MSNBC
personalities will be talking about
Civil War and one of them will say we
may have to be fighting our neighbors a
man walking down the street in Portland
will be shot twice in the chest by a man
with a communist tattoo on his neck the
red salute nobody would have believed
you
and today people are acting like nothing
crazy is happening it's like stop being
the frog in the Boiling Pot the average
person jump out doesn't know about the
the guy getting shot with the yeah
that's like that's my biggest problem
it's like most of my friends if they're
not politically partisan the ones that I
don't agree with but we can at least
agree to disagree the average person
just doesn't know that stuff is going on
there they if it's not being you talked
about Donald Trump report you know going
to these sites that hate him to get his
message out there that's part of the
problem that's but these other states
they're not talking about this that you
know when that happened I still remember
that nobody heard about that in the
regular news nobody around me I think I
think that's the problem too you know
these these people don't want to be
political you know it's Doomsday News
all the time all the time they think
they're leading this happy life but you
know ultimately they're not voting
they're not doing anything and the next
thing you know
like their kids are coming home with
these crazy messages and they're I mean
I I don't know I wish I wish I felt like
I could be non-political but I I care
too much and I think
I think you know you guys obviously do
that's why we're here yeah we had this
attempt tweeted this Plato quote about
uh if you don't get involved in politics
the politics will get involved with you
well he says the penalty for not being
involved is to be ruled by evil and then
you juxtapose that with Dan tone uh who
said I'd rather have been a poor
fisherman than to have meddled in the
politics of man what I started thinking
is Dan tone was cynical he was angry and
violent the entire time and he was just
lashing out of course you're supposed to
be involved with politics here let me
let me read these quotes Plato said the
price of Good Men pay for indifference
to public affairs is to be ruled by evil
men correct and Antone said oh it were
better to be a poor fisherman than to
meddle with the government of men that
is not true that is an Fu to people
because he was angry that they were
about to execute him that's right he
knows you have to be involved in the
political process you don't have to be
partisan but you need to be involved in
what's going on you need to know what's
going on and be willing to communicate
and be willing to listen
it is the basis of our government is the
P we the people created this thing
together and we're we're running this
thing
yeah I think that's a personal
reflection on the part of dantone I
think it was very a sense of deep regret
and frustration that he did what he did
I don't know if he ever realized or said
that it was something that needed to be
done but at the end of the day it even
if you regret doing something sometimes
it's sometimes it is far better to have
done that thing than to have not done it
man no better example
of living by The Sword and dying by the
sword or diamond sword then robe Spear
and Anton yeah I was thinking last night
the U.S Revolution the French Revolution
and the Frenchman they had it tough
because the King was there with them on
their soil like we were far away and
they had they ended up cutting all these
people's heads off with the guillotine
like could they have won that Revolution
if they hadn't done that I don't know
well and that's the danger of monarchy
it makes people crazy and desperate
think about the the Russian Revolution
when or not Russian but Soviets or
however you call it when they when they
brought the royal family and were like
yeah just wait here and then later came
back and just kill them all yeah they
were like the problem is if you're
around you'll have influence so you're
dead these people are dangerous crazy
people the French Revolution is man
people you got to read about that I've
only read a little bit but I'm reading
more and y'all should read about it
because it was a group of people there
was anger in the streets they were
starving so they have a revolution it
happens then a bunch of different
factions are all in a Mexican standoff
over who's gonna get who's gonna chop
off whose head and they all start
executing each other and everyone and
then finally Robespierre gets it and
they're like yay
finally killed the last person who is
trying to get power
creepy and then Napoleon seized command
and became an emperor that's what
happens with that nonsense that's great
and then you get the Napoleonic Wars we
do not want to fight our neighbors to be
clear the the Nazis separated people
from their neighbors the Communists in
Russia separated people from their
neighbors they had their neighbors
spying turning in their neighbors their
kids
so I understand Nance's frustration if
it's and fear I get that he is afraid
but right now you need to be
communicating with your neighbors and
creating Community with your neighbors
if you run out of food you need to make
sure that your neighborhood is secure
together and that you all have enough
food to eat you need to import the food
make sure the roads are clear have
Community Watch
I think Malcolm Nance saying this is a
sure sign that he hasn't talked to
another actual person outside his bubble
in a very long time there are a lot of
normal people saying that there who just
want to take their kids to school
without masks and they'll argue about
that with other people they're not
terrorists they're working they're
trying to provide their family they
don't have time this local school board
who has time right let me read what he
said he said a year and a half ago when
I was calling as an Insurgency people
were saying that's crazy this isn't an
Insurgency this isn't like Iraq it's not
like Libya it's not like Syria well it
is it's well in its way it's closer to
the beginnings of the Irish Republican
Army you know Irish republicanism where
now the Republican party is Sin Fine is
how you pronounce it yes it's in fine uh
and it's just a matter of seeing who
comes up as the original Irish
Republicans in this story and starts
carrying out acts of violence to effect
change that's already happening with
anti-fots been happening so we are well
on our way to a multi-year campaign that
we are already two years into into this
campaign where we may have to fight them
the they in my title and the they in my
title is those who want to kill
Americans are your neighbors
that's so horrible
if we don't have a king man we don't
have a monarch
y
oh I think this is a typo from Breitbart
maybe the they in my title
and those who want to kill Americans are
your neighbors or I don't know okay you
better refer to a they and the title of
his article but yeah to me it just
sounds like he's calling you to
judic streets and uh get into it with
your own neighbors insane the Irish
Republicans wanted out of the British
Empire they were stuck under Imperial
rule they didn't like it that's not what
we're going through right now we're
suffering a bank default basically
the people on the left think that it's a
white supremacist 1619 government and
they look
Hue controls the past controls the
future is that the saying yeah you
control or or no that's not what it is
is it let me look it up not sure that
sounded right to me yeah because like
there's like a full quo it's like who
controls the future controls the present
or something
yeah present will be controlled by those
who in the past lived in the future
vice president yeah right is that you
have the quote no I'm pulling it up
Sorry my phone's really slow I had to
update it you're saying who writes the
history books is sort of predominating
the future you go to people and say hey
did you know that guy stole from you and
you go he did yeah he stole from you why
did he steal from me because of your
race like but I can't do anything about
that um you should beat him up and
that's what you end up getting you get
these extremists who are advocating for
this crazy stuff okay here's the quote
who controls the past controls the
future who controls the present controls
the past yeah there you go yeah works
out that's powerful and that's sourcing
with people like Malcolm Nance yeah
um the idea it's possible he's just so
dumb that he doesn't know how to read or
he doesn't want to read I don't buy that
anymore yeah I I used to be one of the
people that gave people the benefit of
the doubt and thought you know maybe
they just don't know maybe they're
zombies I don't I don't buy that anymore
I don't think so yeah so if that's the
case then it's intentional he's
intentionally trying to manipulate the
facts the data history to cause people
to be violent
this is this is the point I was making
with my op-ed in Newsweek Jamie Raskin
who represents a district
like two miles away from us
who represents some of the employees
here at timcast was was spreading
disinformation to radicalize people yep
because they want violence yeah so his
article reads more like a wish than a
warning it sounds like this is exactly
what he wants that's what he's been
gunning for he's been sounds like
calling for it for a long time the idea
that he said that incredible that we
that we what he says that uh where we
may have to fight them
that's outright psychotic like I get it
you do want to prepare for the worst you
want to be that's why people arm
themselves in the U.S so we have the
Second Amendment a big part of this
because if if you get a totalitarian
government could be your neighbors or
whatever you need to be able to defend
yourself I understand the sentiment but
there's a there's a there's like a a
point where preparing and living in fear
no longer is defensive but becomes
offensive and we got to make sure that
people that spew rhetoric like this do
not incite people to attack their
neighbors preemptively thanks for
checking out this clip from timcast IRL
come hang out live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm Eastern Time Super Chat will
even answer some of your questions if
you want to check out the after hours
censored show go to timcast.com and
become a member we put those up Monday
through Thursday at 11 PM they're very
funny not very family friendly we'll
love to see you there thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time